A few days ago on July 25th, I published
an article marking the feast of Spain's
patron saint. James, son of Zebedee.
Known in Christian tradition as the
elder brother of John the Evangelist. He
was for more than a thousand years far
more famously revered as Santiago
Matamorus, St. James the Moore, that is
Muslim slayer. He was the very
embodiment of Spain's centuriesl long
struggle to reclaim its land and faith
from Islamic rule. Now, a few days
later, I want to share the story again.
This time in video form. After all, in
an age when the memory of Christian
resistance is being deliberately erased,
his story demands to be told and
remembered. Okay. In the year 7-Eleven,
Muslim armies from North Africa flooded
into Christian Spain, which had been
evangelized by St. James himself in the
1st century AD. I've already detailed
the atrocities committed during this
invasion. See chapters 3 and six,
especially of my sword and scimitar. But
for our purposes, two points stand out.
First, not all of the Iberian Peninsula
was conquered. A remnant of Christians
who refused to submit to Muslim rule
retreated into the mountainous northwest
into Aurius. Second, the Muslim
aggression against his Christian enclave
continued for decades until a fragile
peace was imposed on the humiliating
condition that the Christian king of
Aurius sent 100 of the prettiest virgin
girls each year to the Emir Cordoba.
This grotesque tribute continued for
decades until sometime after King Ramiro
I ascended to the throne and defiantly
refused to send any more Christian girls
to Muslim harams. Swift and terrible was
the Muslim response. Romero's resistance
wasn't seen as mere rebellion. It was a
blasphemous affront to Islamic
supremacy. So in retaliation, the Amir
of Cordoba sent a massive army north to
crush the defiant Christians once and
for all. According to the chronicles,
the Muslim force numbered 60,000 Arab
and Berber cavalry and infantry drawn
from all across Elandaloo. Ramiro,
vastly outnumbered, could barely rally
only 5,000 Christian fighters. The two
armies met near Clavho in the rugged
hills of La Rioa. The Christians
prepared themselves for annihilation. As
night fell, Ramiro withdrew to his tents
and prayed. And that night, heaven
answered, "St. James the Greater,
apostle of Christ, evangelizer of Spain,
appeared to him in a vision, radiant,
sword drawn, a stride a white horse. He
promised to ride with a Christian army
into battle and crush the enemies of
Christ. St. James fights for us, King
Ramiro was heard crying before dawn,
stirring his bewildered, sleepy men. Let
the enemies of Christ fall beneath his
sword. As sunlight broke across the
hills on May 23 in the year 844,
Christian soldiers reported seeing a
dazzling figure on horseback charging
from the mountains. It was Santiago
shining in celestial armor cutting
through Muslim ranks like divine
lightning. With the rallying cry St.
James and strike for Spain, the
Christians charged, emboldened by the
presence of their heavenly commander.
What should have been a massacre became
a miracle. The Cordovan army was
shattered and routed. Later accounts
claimed every last Muslim soldier was
slain. Romero emerged victorious and
vowed eternal devotion to St. James. He
pledged to build churches in the
apostles honor, to make a yearly
pilgrimage to his tomb at Santiago de
Compasto, and to honor him as patron and
protector of Spain. As for the
humiliating annual tribute of 100 virgin
girls, it became a bad memory. Over
time, Santiago Matamoros, St. James, a
Muslim slayer, became enshrined in the
very soul of Christian Spain. He was
immortalized in art and sculpture, sword
raised high, trampling Muslims beneath
the hooves of his white charger.
Centuries later, a Castellian noble
would shout, "With Santiago leading us,
we shall trample the crescent beneath
the hooves of our horses." At the
decisive battle of Las Talooa in 1212,
which broke the Muslim yoke once and for
all, another chronicler wrote,
"Santiago, destroyer of Moors, has
descended from heaven with a burning
sword. Praise be to God who has shown us
his champion. Even Muslim chronicers
took note of this fearsome apparition
and the devotion he stirred. HB
complained centuries later, quote, "The
Franks call upon a dead apostle and yet
their banners advance while ours
retreat." Needless to say, and as might
be expected, modern academics starting
in 1968 concluded that the battle of
Cladho never even happened. Be that as
it may, what is undeniable is this. For
over a thousand years, Christian Spain
believed it happened. And that belief
shaped the Spanish soul. The reconista
was no mere war. It was holy retribution
with St. James as a divine avenger
against Islam's persecution of
Christendom. Indeed, a thousand years
after Clavho, here is how the famous Dom
Prosper Garinger,
the French architect of the modern
liturggical revival, reflected on the
legacy of St. James the Morslayer when
he was writing in the 19th century. He
wrote, quote, nearly eight centuries had
passed over that tomb of St. James in
the north of Spain when lights were seen
glimmering over the briars that covered
the neglected monument. What are those
sudden shouts from the mountains? Who is
this unknown chief rallying a doomed
band against an immense army? Swift as
lightning, and bearing in one hand a
white standard with a red cross, he
rushes withdrawn sword upon the
panic-stricken foe, and dies the feet of
his charger in the blood of 70,000
slain. Hail to the chief of the holy
war, St. James, St. James, forward,
Spain. It is the reappearance of the
Galilean fisherman whom the man god once
called from the bark where he was
mending his nets. It is the reappearance
of the elder son of thunder, now free to
hurl the thunderbolt upon these new
Samaritans who pretend to honor the
unity of God by making Christ no more
than a prophet. He's referring to the
Muhammadans. That far more than a memory
of a saint was what July 25th once
commemorated in Spain. The unyielding
spirit of a civilization that refused to
bow. St. James was not merely a figure
of piety. He was a blazing symbol of
Christian defiance, a rallying call to
arms against those who sought to erase
the faith from Spain, namely Muslims.
For centuries, he stood at the very
heart of a national identity forged in
resistance and renewal. Today, that
legacy is being dismantled not by
invading Muslim armies, but by Spain's
own so-called elites, who in the name of
tolerance and diversity have chosen to
erase their past. St. James the
Morslayer, once hailed as the divine
protector of Spain, is now treated as a
relic of shame, an embarrassment to be
cancelled out of public memory.
Meanwhile, as these elites rewrite
history, Muslim migrants across Europe,
including in Spain, are once again
engaging in acts of anti-Christian
violence, desecrating churches, smashing
crosses, and committing crimes,
including much rape and murder, against
the very communities whose ancestors
once fought to preserve their faith and
land. This isn't coincidence. Its
surrender and what a nation forgets it
forfeits.